cette autre déclaration de jean luc
mélenchon cette semaine c'était dans
dans la provence
et cette fois ci il vise et benoît hamon
benoît hamon n'a pas été capable de
prendre la décision qu'il fallait
prendre c'est à dire se retirer lors de
la course à la présidentielle s'il
s'était retirée il serait aujourd'hui
premier ministre et moi président de la
république franchement vous y croyez
alors il est intéressant mais je pense
qu'effectivement comme dirait qu'il est
il est au dessus se situe très au dessus
d'ailleurs il se situe en face à face
avec un maquereau est d'ailleurs une
amie je suis l'opposition et
effectivement il est l'opposition il est
président tous la frontière a l'air
assez ténues dans son esprit et ce face
à face est intéressant parce qu'il se
fait que la complexité des manuels mac
rookie qui a comme en une un intérêt
dans ce cas passe puisque mêlant chant
aussi c'est les meilleurs mais ce qu'il
dit dans la table alors sais plus quel
meilleur ennemi je pense que en fait
c'est un couple qui peut durer et ça
mais c'est un couple qui se fait du mal
puisqu'en fait
macron ce divin ce mélenchon il n'est
pas crédible et il est excessif et
mélenchon se dit macway n'a rien compris
d'ailleurs ils lisent l'un et l'autre
qui se répondent dans l'interview lundi
mme à kronach y compris et macron dit
né en chant n'a pas de programme pour
les déshérités et d'ailleurs vous dites
c'est jean luc mélenchon répond ah oui
oui mais voilà le paradis des formes
très amusant et malgré tout ce qu'on
peut se fait du mal parce que l'un fait
un travail de sape ac qui peut être
assez productif
mélenchon a très bien compris que la lgv
au travail c'était pas gagné mais que
par contre il allait essayer de fédérer
internés contentement mais inversement
mélenchon peut se marient lepénisé
c'est-à-dire perte de stature
présidentielle dans des excès verbaux
alors de menaces